in the last video we saw how there could
be an industry that has two firms the
duopoly and if those two farms
coordinate they could behave as a
monopolist and they could optimize their
collective economic profit and in the
last video we saw that would happen when
they produced 50 units per period and
they could split it assuming these were
two identical firms by each producing
half of it in the case of the last video
it was 250 units per firm but then we
saw that there was an incentive to cheat
that by producing extra units the margin
from a markets point of view the
marginal economic or the economic profit
on those incremental units would be
negative so the whole economic profit
would get would shrink a little bit as
you produce units beyond that but the
cheater would get a bigger chunk of
those units or the bigger chunk of that
economic profit and so the cheater could
actually gain go from $250 per time
period to 280 and it would be all at the
expense of the non-cheater who and and
then some who would lose even more than
what the cheater gained and obviously
the who is initially the non-cheater has
an incentive now to cheat and they'll
both keep increasing they'll both keep
increasing production so that if they've
wanted to keep doing this one-upsmanship
and so they'll both they both have the
incentive to keep going assuming that
they don't hold to their cartel
agreement until you get to a quantity
until you get to a quantity where the
where there is no economic profit left
so right over here the way I've drawn it
the demand curve intersects the average
total cost curve right over here and
there is no economic profit left we're
producing a good quantity it looks like
it's about 75 units combined 75 units
for the whole market but at this point
the market price the market price is
equal to the average total cost and so
there's no economic profit per unit on
average now what I want to do is think
about this in kind of a game theoretic
way so let's look at a bunch of states
and so this is the optimal state that we
are starting off in and you can actually
call it the Pareto optimal state Pareto
optimal Pareto optimal
State named after vilfredo pareto and
all it means is that's the state where
there's no other state where you can
make someone better off without making
the other person worse off so any of the
states here there are states for example
where blue is better off so for example
in this state right over here blue is
better off but green is worse off so
that's why it's called Pareto Pareto
optimality now what I want to think
about is how these these characters will
change their state due to their
incentives and then we'll talk a little
bit about Nash equilibrium as well so on
this axis on the up here let's say that
this is one of the competitors this is
where they produce 25 and let's say on
the ultimate cheating quantity of 75
where and this is somewhat close to kind
of the market or that is the equilibrium
quantity if this was a completely and
this was perfect competition they
produce half of that so this is then
producing 37 and a half units and as we
go from 25 to 30 seven and a half units
they are cheating more so this is more
more cheating and over here this was no
cheating and we can do the same thing
for the blue player and I'll write them
as B this is them producing 25 this is
them producing 37 and a half and as we
go up and up and up they are cheating
more so this is a lot of cheating or
more more cheating so to think of it in
the game theoretical way this is the
Pareto optimal state right over here and
it's it's optimal in many ways this is
they've maximized the total economic
profit here there's no other state that
one person would benefit without making
the other worse now let's think about
whether this is a Nash equilibrium so
let's remind ourselves what Nash what
Nash equilibrium was this was a state
where holding other all the other
players constant so in this case there's
only one other player holding others
others constant others constant a player
can't gain by changing strategy player
player can't gain by changing strategy
in this case changing strategy is
changing your output
by changing changing strategy so let's
see if that is true of this state right
over here well let's hold a constant if
a is constant where in this column right
over here is there something B can do is
there change or strategy B can do that
would allow B to game well sure B can
increase production that's what we saw
in the last video so we would go from
this bottom right state to 1 right above
it now B's economic profit is 280 a is
200 the pie has shrunk but B has got a
larger chunk of it so that was not a
Nash equilibrium there is there is
holding all others constant of play
there is a player that can gain the by
changing their strategy and this is by
holding the Nash equilibrium definition
just to make sure they say it's a state
we're holding others constant no player
no player can gain by genic strategy we
just show that at least one player can
gain by changing strategy holding others
constant and the same would be true if
we went the other way around
if we held B constant at 25 a could gain
by changing his strategy could go right
over there
so this is not a Nash equilibrium so
this is not a Nash equilibrium and then
regardless of what state we go to if we
go to this state it's still not a Nash
equilibrium if we hold a constant B can
improve by increasing his production or
if we hold B constant then a can still
improve by cheating even more so none of
these are Nash equilibriums from any one
of these state if you hold a constant B
could produce more or if you hold B
constant a could produce more and get
and get some gain over here a is going
from 130 to 160 and getting some gain
and you could imagine this keeps
happening incrementally they keep
producing more and more and more we kind
of go there then we go there then maybe
we go there then we go there then then
maybe a cheat some more then be cheat
some more than a cheats a little bit
more B cheats a little bit more maybe a
little bit more past that then a cheats
a little bit more the whole time the
whole economic profit PI which is the
sum of a and B gets getting smaller and
smaller until finally a finally cheats
and they are at zero economic
profit now let's think about whether
this is a Nash equilibrium clearly they
won't want to move backwards if you hold
a constant B would not want to go from
would not want to move down then he
would lose economic profit so that's
that doesn't work he doesn't gain by
doing that if you old B constant a
wouldn't want to move to the right a
would also lose economic profit now you
might say well what if they produced
beyond thirty seven and a half why can't
they keep producing and go beyond there
well if they if be holding a constant if
B were to produce more than thirty seven
and a half from this state right over
here then the total pie will get
negative and it doesn't matter if he's
getting a larger or smaller chunk of
that pie B's chunk is going to be
negative he's going to drive down the
price even more and you can see it over
here if they increase quantity beyond
this market quantity of seventy five
thirty seven and a half each if we go
beyond that the the price the the price
that they would be selling at at that
quantity over there is lower than the
average total cost and so you're going
to be the total economic the average
economic profit per unit is going to be
negative there will be a total of
negative economic profit so neither of
them will want to produce more from this
state either so all of a sudden in this
top left state holding others constant B
if you hold a constant B can't gain by
changing his strategy and if you hold B
constant a can't gain by changing his
strategy and so we are up here we are up
here in a Nash equilibrium this is a
Nash equilibrium and like the prisoner's
dilemma equilibrium it was not the
optimal state the optimal state was here
but because they both wanted to cheat
they both want to do this one-upsmanship
they both broke their contracts they
could end up in this state over here but
this state is stable there's nothing
holding the other party equal there's
nothing that they could do to change to
to optimize now what they could do and
this is not what national applies to
they could say oK we've been really
ruining each other's business
let's go coordinated n and I'm going to
decrease production if you decrease
production now that is not and they
could maybe try to go back to this date
and that does not mean that this is not
a Nash
equilibrium because by coordinating
again we're not holding the others
constant we're like we're saying I'm
changing my strategy while you're
changing your strategy and so maybe only
through another agreement they could go
over here but that still doesn't mean
that this is not a Nash equilibrium this
is a Nash equilibrium if you if there's
no coordination if you hold one player
constant the other player cannot change
their strategy or change their
production for a game